merci merci merci
est-ce que les scpi
est ce que votre corps tient encore le
coup
[Applaudissements]
il ya l'association des cardiologues qui
seront à la porte pour prendre votre
pression au sortant en sortant
quelle soirée quelle soirée merci de
votre patience désolé de tout c'est
peut-être cette durée interminable pour
vous merci d'être resté on est content
de finir cette soirée là avec vous
[Applaudissements]
encore ce soir
qui vient conforter fier que ff déjoue
les pronostics
mais force est de constater au moment je
m'adresse à vous qui est encore trop tôt
pour conclure une fois devant moi un
petit crochet roux je veux entendre
avant avoir d'aller plus loin d'avoir
une officialisation pour l'instant quand
je suis rentré dans sa vie est encore
trop tôt pour conclure c'est quoi
l'issue de cette élection mais
certainement pas trop tôt pour saluer
cette équipe de passionnés de kiev 2-1
dévié
celle qui a été avec us
mais aussi celle de tous les autres
partis
ces gens n'ont plus à une aventure qui
n'était pas nécessairement gagné
d'avancé ce n'était pas facile et pour
lequel on avait derrière devant nous un
grand trajet à parcourir ils nous ont
donné de la force la confiance ils ont
plus grande autres douter alors à
chacune et chacun des ventes et une
personne et j'ajoute açores nos
bénévoles nos gens engagés les gens qui
en auraient quand c'est énorme à la
salle qui ont cru au point de donner des
arts qui avait pas là vous avez fait la
différence vous faites la différence
merci d'y croire on a levé la battait
et prenons le temps s'il vous plaît de
réaliser le fruit d'une année d'efforts
d'une année d'efforts qui sera on
l'espère couronnée d'un succès annoncé
par l'officialisation des résultats
mais rappelons nous s'il vous plaît
rappelons-nous qui a presque un an jour
pour jour on était à un pour ça
on était un pur sa
peau non
au nom pas encore deux parties un chef à
peu près inconnu du grand public même
pas connu du maire en place
et il y avait une pandémie
est aussi une élection fédérale qui est
venu s'ajouter sur notre chemin
les vieux de la vieille faisait vie
arriverez porte pas connue avec tous cas
devant vous une élection fédérale ça va
être trop compliqué mais on partageait
quelque chose en commun qui est l'amour
de notre ville
beaucoup d'audace oui tout à fait
beaucoup d'audace certains disaient de
la folie
on partage est surtout une conviction
une conviction puissante qui allait se
transformer en étincelles
québec avait besoin d'un renouveau d'une
nouvelle voie
l'équipe aux grandes idées collaboration
des collaborateurs issus d'horizons
variés se sont joints et ont décidé
d'acheter leur voix la nôtre
rarement at-on vu à québec un libéral un
péquiste une solidaire
une cas qu'il se réunir et avoir du fun
ensemble les personnes parties
[Musique]
vous laisse deviner qui est qui
les élections municipales ont cette
particularité de rassembler les gens et
ça pour moi c'est probablement le plus
grand des apprentissages des derniers
moore rassembler du monde des femmes et
des hommes qui ont levé la main pour
dire qu'on doit donner encore plus
d'amour à nos quartiers
que les aînés dans cette ville doivent
avoir une place d'importance pour juste
représenter le passé mais est notre
présent et notre avenir tout à fait
de dire qu'on peut construire des
quartiers hans préoccupant dit grandir
dû grandir en sécurité développer des
équipements sportifs la proximité d'où
les gens vivaient dit vieillir longtemps
et c'est ça qu'on va faire avec
l'ensemble des élus de cette nouvelle
administration la
nombreux à dire qu'on doit accélérer la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
qu'on doit prendre soin de nos plus
démunis condos mieux protéger et mettre
en valeur notre patrimoine soutenir plus
vigoureusement nos entrepreneurs nous
commerçants qu'on ne doit laisser perdre
et tout à fait qu'on ne doit laisser
personne derrière il se sera notre
métropole à chacun des jours du prochain
mandat ne laissez jamais personne
derrière
la ville de québec a besoin de cette
énergie cette énergie qu'on a senti dans
la campagne qu'on sent ce soir il faut
qu'elle perdure il faut qu'on la mène
avec nous parce que les défis devant
nous sont grands les défis devant nous
sont importants et si on se réunit pont
on y arrivera pour
jour après jour semaine après semaine
porte après porte on a senti un écho
grande île à travers la population et
c'est cet appui de gens qu'on rencontre
sur le terrain que nourrit note
étincelle que nourrit nos candidats en
faire plus que nourrit nos candidates à
continuer sur ce chemin qui étaient
parfois sinueux c'était un sens plus la
campagne avançait plus on la voyait dans
les yeux des autres listes à partir de
ce moment considère n'est pas seul à
rêver on n'est pas seul à rêver et tout
au long de sort on n'a jamais fait de
compromis sur notre engagement dans
cette campagne date énergie à investir
le meilleur de nous mêmes sur l'ensemble
des efforts qu'on devait déployer sur la
conviction qu'on porte le meilleur
projet pour les gens de québec et je
crois que c'est tout à votre honneur et
c'est tout à notre honneur d'avoir
maintenu le cap et de l'avoir fait avec
force avec détermination et avec
persévérance
merci mille sont
dans tous les corps il faut dire que
c'est toute une page d'histoire de notre
ville qui se tourne ce soir je tiens à
saluer monsieur labeaume monsieur le
maire je tiens à vous remercier vous
témoigner mon respect pour vos 14 années
passées a représenté avec passion fog
les citoyens et citoyennes du québec
tient à saluer l'ensemble des autres
élus de la région et du québec qui ce
soir prennent à bras le corps une
nouvelle mission de protéger défendre
leur ville faire face aux enjeux qui
sont les leurs et je dis qu'on va
collaborer avec eux je veux saluer
particulièrement madame plan pour sa
réélection à montréal
et monsieur gilles lehouillier à lévis
nous allons collaborer ensemble nous
allons arrêter de bâtir nos villes dos
au fleuve nous allons rebâtir une région
forte et prospère avec tous les maires
de cette grande agglomération
mais mes derniers remerciements et non
les moindres je veux les partager avec
les autres candidats la mairie qui ont
donné le meilleur demain madame smith
monsieur rousseau monsieur gosselin marc
savard cette campagne est une campagne
éreintante pour tous notamment pour les
chefs je lis à lui bien beau jeu
reconnaît leur engagement leur passion
pour la ville c'est ce que ça prend dans
une démocratie forte des gens qui ont le
courage que ces gens l'ont eue de
s'afficher d'aller de l'avant de faire
face à la musique bravo pour votre
engagement notre ville en a bien besoin
permettez-moi en terminant
de finir ses discours en formulant un
sou est un
sou et que je sais que vous partagez
avec moi
que le nouveau conseil municipal
sont marqués par l'optimisme par un
dynamisme d'ouverture et de
collaboration entre tous ses membres peu
importe leur appartenance politique
qu'il soit près des citoyens qu'ils
soient à l'écouté qu'ils favorisent
l'engagement de tous et toutes à travers
les grands et petits projets de la ville
qu'ils soient plus sensibles aux
différentes réalités dans chacun de nos
quartiers qu'ils posent des gestes
vigoureux pour faire face à l'urgence
des changements climatiques qu'il se
donne comme objectif de réunir tous les
citoyens que nous soyons les 21 élus et
moi représentants de tous les citoyens
et non pas d'une allégeance d'un
district ou d'un courant de pensée mais
qu'on développe cette ville-là ensemble
les défis qui sont devant nous nécessite
qu'on se rassemble nécessite qu'on
s'unisse parce que c'est pas se diviser
qu'on va réussir je pense comprendre
tout ça avoir une ville moins polarisé
je m'y engage je m'engage à travailler
avec tous les élus à le faire de façon
collaborative à le faire de façon avec
un leadership tiendra compte de leur
opinion qui tiendra compte de tous les
citoyens dans cette ville on a décidé
qu'on a fondé québec forte et fière de
ne pas faire de politique de niche ne
pas opposer les uns contre les autres la
périphérie contre le semble l'autobus
contre loto de faire en sorte que le
quartier versus un autre mais de dire
cette ville laval a développé que tous
les citoyens et c'est ce que je m'engage
c'est ce que les gens derrière moi
s'engagent aussi à faire on veut
construire une ville de québec forte on
va construire une ville de québec fier
mais on le fera pas sans vous merci
beaucoup on commence demain
merci tout le monde
[Applaudissements]